Martin Schultz has been described as mr.
Europe a committed European and the face
of the European Parliament Schultz has
been in Brussels fighting for a stronger
EU for 21 years he passionately defended
Europe in his acceptance speech here
dummy Dolph stop blaming Brussels for
all the things that go wrong and all the
unresolved problems while pinning every
success to your national flags far
that's true Schultz is a passionate
politician who's not afraid of speaking
his mind he recently called on EU member
states to take on more responsibility in
dealing with the refugee crisis in the
Mediterranean the intraluminal ball
decision on whether to make progress
will be made in Brussels but only
geographically speaking it won't be made
in Brussels institutions but rather in
Berlin Rome London and Madrid in London
in Madrid German President Joachim Gauck
and French president Francois Hollande
were among the many high-ranking guests
at the ceremony Germany's president used
his speech to back Schultz his call for
a swift solution to the refugee crisis
jalan oh ho / China I inferi Europe
cannot find a common solution on how to
handle the influx of refugees in for
Lincoln their national governments must
take a leading role this is about saving
lives this get double mention names
written the refugee crisis is just one
of the issues facing Europe and the new
Charlemagne Prize laureate martin schulz